the beaded tattoo cartridge two with a
ratchet and the dragons will come and
they sound the drum in a minute or two
to two today at a minute two to two
[Music]
hi welcome to my class a voiceover booth
can get a little claustrophobic so
how about we do this what better way to
learn about voice acting than from an
animated character
i'm going to tell you a little story
about a girl from
ohio the girl got a job at a radio
station where she saw that you could
make a living
with your voice so she worked her way up
and eventually did voices for hit
cartoons
it took me getting cast on the simpsons
that i realized that i
excelled in doing quirky tomboys
all right in this class i'll teach you
everything about voice acting how to
develop your characters
this is just a little character that i
can use as our example
one of the things that you can do is to
change the pitch of your character
i can make him a little bit lower like
this
or i can lift him way up high like this
performance tips
and how to start out in the industry
nobody knows what you look like
they don't know how old you are they
don't know anything about you it's just
your voice
so anybody can do it and i'll
demonstrate how i bring animation to
life
by voicing several original characters
from a show we made
called no effort girl i didn't ask you
to be born with super strength
x-ray vision and the ability to fly ugh
you'll learn how to distinguish your
characters so they take on
a life of their own so let's get started
i'm nancy cartwright and this is my mom
wait
what are you doing i'm doing the master
class line but i'm the real nancy
i'll do it i'm nancy cartwright i'm
nancy cutwite
and this is my master class
[Music]
me
[Music]
you